Isn't that surprising
that as your income rises
if you're black
you're more likely
to get pulled over by the police.
Is the idea behind that, like
"Oh, you're driving a better car."
and for a cop that's a flag.
Like, "Why would a black man
be driving a newer car?"
It seems to be that.
Hi,  I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and we
are at the International Students for
Liberty Conference 2017 talking to Cato's
Emily Ekins, she's the director of polling
and a senior research fellow.
Emily, thanks for talking to us.
Thanks for having me.
You've been doing a bunch of stuff that
is fascinating about criminal justice
issues and the ways that different types
of Americans view the police.
When you ask people including people of
different groups who may or may not feel
they're being disfavored by cops
they agree on what the police should be doing.
Yes.
What should the police be doing and
you know, what do you find there?
Well to reiterate your first point
we often focus a lot of attention on
these big racial gaps in confidence
toward the police. You know; how they do
their jobs, are they accountable,
do they use too much force.